hi everyone um
so i'm going to start well with an
apology i've got a bit of a cough so
you'll have to forgive me if that
happens um
and then the second thing i'm going to
start with is a disclaimer because we
are a hedge fund um and i have to like
um you know they have to protect
themselves from me saying anything
stupid so uh it is completely my opinion
um yeah if i say anything silly um so uh
well let's start with who am i my name
is john ballister
as she said i run the data science
engineering team
um i joined about five years ago
and i've been kind of involved in
notebooks
since i started
we have the concept of 10 time so that
means you can kind of do whatever you
like um and i chose to
work with and around tubes and notebooks
um especially because we work a lot with
the analysts and data scientists within
mangrove
so i wrote notebooker which is now
available on github if you want to have
a go
while i'm talking um
and yeah so let's get started um so i
guess
to start with why jupiter notebooks um
why would you want to productionize them
i mean they're great right
there's no contesting that they're
fantastic tools for research they're
good for kind of quick analysis you get
instant feedback um it's really easy for
someone to pick it up and just start
typing and really get um you know
in some feedback as to what they're
doing it works for all sorts of
languages um but mostly i'm going to
focus on markdown and python because
that's kind of what we use internally
um the problem is that they're also
awful um
and you know that
if someone gave me a jupiter notebook
and said productionize this uh i would
think very well
terrible thoughts um so
yeah you know they're right once you
know um you may rerun it later on um but
you might forget what you did you might
um not you know get the same result that
you did before
um
it's really difficult to review them
there are tools out there um i'm going
to talk about this a little bit later on
um they're quite difficult to test
there's again there's tools out there um
but actually to ensure that they always
work the way you expect them to
is tricky um
another problem is that if you're handed
a jeep to notebook that someone else ran
um they'll be in all sorts of orders you
know because you can kind of run it
whenever and it's got constant states so
and they're not stateless they're very
much if you run it in this order then
delete a cell you'll still get that
parameter in memory um so a little bit
scary um
and finally
if you ran it three weeks ago
and you've ran it since you lose that
result three weeks ago so um that's
that's a bit annoying
but actually if we can get rid of all
these problems then it becomes quite
trivial to production as in a book and
it's quite nice so how does a notebooker
address this um and how could you
address this perhaps if you if you chose
to use notebook or well not um so first
one is papermill
papermill is an open source
project
which is by interact um
and it
grew with popularity due to a blog from
netflix netflix used this in production
to deploy their machine learning models
um which
you would say is crazy um but actually
you know seems to work really nicely for
them
in terms of code review you can actually
use a tool called dupytext which allows
you to interchangeably convert between
ipad notebook and python
if you are given python to review that's
fine if you're given an ipad notebook
you'll see in a second
um to actually regression test if it's
python you can just run it in pi test
and you can see if it works um if and if
you know it fails then it fails and you
kind of onsen very quickly so for us we
can actually just execute the notebook
and see if it works or not
um again papermill is really good for
the execution thing papermill will
literally take any parameters that you
want to add to your notebook
and then it will just execute in order
so there's no questioning about the
order of execution it will just go from
the top to the bottom
and then finally historical results
there's no booker so notebooker kind of
wraps all these things into one nice
package
it saves things into the database
so that actually you can search retrieve
later on um and it kind of just yeah it
works as a big package to
have your reports kind of as a
production quality report
um so i mean what are the alternatives
um
there are loads out there this is not an
exhaustive list by any means um but
voila is really really good it just
needs kind of a running
kind of
environment so you actually need a back
end to be running
in our case we can just have a static
report and that means that you can kind
of have lots and lots of different
iterations um
uh saved into
the database
uh binder is great but it's kind of
jupiter hub
which is also amazing but it just serves
a different purpose and there's actually
a thing called computer which
is very similar to notebook in that you
can view historical results
um but it's just actually from your file
system so you need to have a very well
organized file system and a way to
retrieve these results or store them
sensibly
um so let's just talk about number guns
and uh
explore what it actually is
um
so
the goal really is that it's it's it's
so simple to use like
that you commit something into gets um
and it immediately becomes available on
the web app
the
second goal really is that you can
schedule your reports um
and by report i mean a jupiter notebook
that has been converted into a template
and then
and then executed
uh you can deploy your changes super
quickly um so yeah you just commit to it
and it's there
and then finally sharing very easily so
having a permanent url for example
so
being able to share the latest results
um so
essentially
yeah
working very nicely as an experience to
kind of collaborate
and show the results of your report um
so in eight steps this is how you would
get your report internet booker or your
notebook into notebook uh the first one
you do is well you write youtube's
notebook obviously um the second one you
do is you and this is optional but uh
you can define one of your cells to be a
parameter cell
this is something that's used by um
papermill
and it allows you to inject some
parameters into your notebook what this
means is it becomes instantly reusable
and you can actually kind of templatize
your jibz notebook
optionally as i say you can use gpi text
to convert from ipad back to python this
makes for much easier reviewing
you commit the notebook to kit you push
the master it becomes available
immediately
and then you run it and you can share
the results very easily with just a kind
of static url
so well let's have a look
so this is a notebook i hope it looks
familiar if not
this is a notebook um
and this is what it looks like inside
notebooker so you can see we've stripped
away all the code you can toggle it um
but the nice thing is that you can
really uh just see the important things
which would be any markdown any tables
um or any charts and graphs things like
that there's a bunch of metadata on the
side which is useful for debugging and
re-running that kind of thing
um but actually how do we get our
notebook into this state so well first
we've got to get it into get and
as kind of part of the code review
process you want to you want to review
the notebook
so
reviewing an iphone notebook is just a
blob of
um
jason is fine
uh and you can kind of understand what's
going on here you can see
there's a map plot lib inline there's
import pandas as pd somewhere in there
it's okay
and then and then you scroll down a
little bit and you see
this this blob of of white and you go
what's what's that
and it just kind of keeps
going
and it's 40 000 characters width so if
you try and put this into any diff tool
it will just be a horrific experience
for everyone involved um
so we use duplicates
and what we do is both it strips the
output um but also all of that kind of
json garbage and it turns it into a nice
kind of python file which means that uh
yeah reviewing is is very simple
um but also you're not stuck with you
know uh 40 000 character lines to review
review
um
so yeah this is just an example of a
change i don't know if you can see it
here but yeah literally it's as simple
as that you can see the one liner that
you've done here uh this is actually
something that we did internally
um we can use uh tools like mbdime uh
github also has nice diff tools for ipad
books now which is why it's optional
so actually you can use ipad notebooks
within notebook now this is indian
futurish
which kind of came from people wanting
to use it even more easily
so because the kind of proliferation of
tools has happened and so like github
bitbucket uh now support ipad books uh
natively
it's uh yeah it's a much more um
easy experience these days uh back in
2018 when this was written it kind of
didn't exist
so yeah what we do is uh we have this
concept of templates so your your
notebook is no longer a notebook it is
it is a template within with with the
view of notebooker
and that means that you can really uh
yeah you can parametrize it you can
reuse it and that's kind of the concept
here
so with a notebook it looks like this
and then when you push to
master it will look like this so this is
our list of reports that we have or
templates
um and you can see you can have
multi-tiers and things like that so you
can kind of name space whatever you're
doing
and then when you execute your notebook
or you want to execute your notebook
you can see here that's the parameter
cell so this is what you've defined
within
your jupiter lab or jupyter notebook
as being the parameters and they are all
overrideable as well
so
let me execute it and it's got a cute
little animation um which i might show
you in a little bit if i'm feeling lucky
um and there we are that's the final
result
um so on the home page
you can see kind of a listing of all the
template names that you've executed over
time and then when you click on one of
these you get the kind of listing of
everything that's ever run within
notebooker
and so you can kind of see there are
some ones that errored here there's
one that completed this one that's
currently running
if it produces pdfs for example
then you will get a little button here
to download it
and if it's been scheduled then again
there would be a little button there
so let's take a little dive into
the depths of notebook and see how it
works
um
so
basically
what we want to do is we want to tell
notebooker to run a template
so how do you do this well you can
either do it on the web app as i just
showed um or you can do it within some
sort of scheduler so within notebook
there is now a scheduler internally
which which is nice but also
you can use anything externally so you
could use jenkins you could use airflow
whatever
and because it all uses the same back
end it just produces the same output so
you ask it to run this template
and you may give it some parameters to
override that parameter cell from before
you remember
uh then tuple text will convert your
template back into an ipad notebook
you'll all go into paper mill
which is the open source library from
before it'll render your results and
then either it'll uh well it will both
email them if you ask for it to email
you um and then it will save to storage
uh in our case we use mongodb but there
are plans to use s3 or kind of any other
storage
so prioritization is just kind of a bit
more of a deep dive into this so
um
if we have in this one the uh the
parameter is the color of this
beautiful graph
um
then you can yeah you can add a
parameter
and override it
and then for example you could run the
report loads of times or with any sort
of color
um
and this is how you edit within jupiter
labs so
if you haven't seen it before this is
the interface where you can add tags to
cells
which is a pretty niche thing to want to
do
but actually in our case this is how we
define what the parameters are
so
publishing uh so
when you save international as i
mentioned you put it into a [ __ ]
database that comes with a little
metadata so when you run it what
parameters you run it with um
what the name of the template was who
executes it that kind of thing um
this means that actually we have a lot
of kind of internal metadata that allows
us to search or do other interesting
things so
we have the ability to say as of this
date
what was the result
or what's the latest successful results
or just kind of a static give us the
latest version of this report um so see
what we run with and with a particular
set of parameters as well and so exactly
that's actually quite powerful because
you basically get permalinks which
say for the set of parameters for this
notebook template um
give me the latest results or the latest
success
um yeah we're basically uh abusing nbc
here uh using a very uh a lot um and
yeah so we're rendering everything is
html but we also can render it as pdf as
well which i'll show you in a little bit
testing is a
fairly
loose use of the term
um but it's actually pretty simple
what you can do is you can do a sanity
check so you can basically say does this
render as a iphone notebook properly um
or um you can do a full regression test
so you can actually execute the whole
report
using pi test that's dead simple
the caveat there is that your notebook
shouldn't do anything so you shouldn't
write to a database by default uh it
shouldn't kind of publish to prometheus
for example um by default because uh it
will do that every time you run the
regression test which is probably not
what you want
um
yeah
so yeah scheduling uh
so you can do all sorts of things um
with team city and well any of these
or well anything really even chrome you
can
set some schedules for your notebooks
you can say i want to run this one every
day i want to run with xyz parameters um
but actually it would be really powerful
to do within the web app itself
um and so recently we added a scheduler
to notebooker and i kind of wanted to go
into a little bit of depth of how i did
this but also
how you could possibly add it to your
own applications as well not just you
know within the scope of notebook
so we obviously use ap scheduler
which
probably stands for automated python
scheduler
um and this is a silly a stupidly simple
way to add a scheduler to your
application
and there's kind of three main concepts
so there's job stores so how do you know
what you want to run
there's
scheduling so when do you want to run it
it can be chrome it can be dates
whatever
and then finally
where you want to execute it so is it in
the background of your application is it
kind of uh using germans or uh async or
whatever really
um
so that sounds great and it's probably
like really difficult to configure right
um
yeah that's it that that's all you need
and so to add this to your application
it's three lines of python
which to me is pretty pretty nice um
but
when you have a web app
you can't really write python within the
web app so you actually need a way to
manage it
um
so we had to write a little bit of
javascript slash html um
and get up and running so that's what it
looks like empty that's what it doesn't
and yeah basically you can see here that
we're using a cron schedule so
it gives you a little
view of how to do this
sorry a view of what's when it happens
next
um
also the overrides it's quite important
and you can add like a custom job title
as well once you've done that it shows
up here
um and in my case i've set it to run
with pdfs and email me so i get this in
my inbox
which is yeah what color is that green
i've done it lime green who knows i'm
colorblind um
and then yeah so it shows up in the
application
as you would expect
so uh
finally i just want to have to show you
what we did in in one case earlier this
year
so within man group we have a team
called the data science data management
team
uh and they came to me and said they
want to create some checks
um
which is fine uh but they wanted me to
write a web app or like some
reporting framework um so i didn't want
to do that um
obviously i didn't say this i'm much
more polite uh so i said let's have a go
notebooker um and the answer was yeah
sure um so how did this go
so
that's how it went so these are my
very informative uh git commits um but
what i'm trying to show here is that we
did really really quick prototyping so
um as you push to get it becomes
immediately available in notebooker to
the users so they can add in their own
parameters and things like that
so
they can run it with whatever they like
they can see the changes immediately
and they can well they can break it um
the permalink that i mentioned before is
actually really helpful so it looks a
bit like this so you've got the latest
equals oh sorry um you've got the name
of the template which is generally
active records you've got latest there
which means just give me the latest
version rather than kind of uuid
and you've got the parameters here so
the data set equals gig's history
so that's very helpful
so
we sent out metrics to prometheus which
is a time series database
that allows you to basically send out
snapshots saying this is the state of
something at this point in time
and it also allows you to go back and
query that so we use it internally for
alerting and monitoring
it allows you to basically get a point
in time history of everything so
in this case we use gauges and we say
the correlation between these data set
environments is 0.9999 whatever
also we can use plotly because we are
rendering these templates statically
within uh with html plotly offline um
allows you to well basically have
interactive plots which is super nice
and just kind of adds another level of
interactivity so this all looks like
this is the end result um
i've kind of zoomed in because that's
obviously impossible to read um but yeah
you can see we've got some interactive
charts there we've got some prometheus
being spat out
and then
we've got a grafana dashboard which sits
on top of proteus it queries prometheus
and this is basically the output of the
notebook report so
in short in the space of basically
well a couple of minutes we already had
something up and running um and within a
few days we pretty much finished the
prototype um and it took a matter of one
or two weeks to actually get the
finished product out so this is really
really good for
quick prototyping
especially when you know there's a lot
of back and forth with with users if you
want to get a report out very quickly
this was great for us
um so
yeah in summary
networker allows you to convert your
chip's notebooks into reports or more
accurately into templates
which means that you can kind of yeah
execute
a reduced version of your tubes and
notebook
and
then uh
parameters great papermill is great
actually um so i recommend you check
that out if this sounds interesting to
you
um
ap scheduler is dead easy to get set up
it's it's ridiculously easy i couldn't
believe i didn't find it earlier um
and then finally networkers you know
has proved really helpful more helpful
than we imagined it would initially um
in four years it's
been used all of this and more within
man
[Music]
for kind of all sorts of things um
reporting dashboards just monitoring
whether your stuff is working
um for even kind of portfolio management
that kind of thing
so this is where it is it's on github
it should be fairly easy to set up those
are three steps which
is available on the github
um
and yeah thanks for listening um i
probably have time for a demo if you're
interested
yeah
cool okay we'll see how that goes then
um
let me have a go
so
where are we
so this is a example of lubrica um it's
pretty uh
yeah you can kind of sit down
um
so we have examples rainbow here which
is obviously a fabulous
name um
but what we've got is
a bunch of reports which have been
executed uh over the last hour or two
um
and what we've been able to do is
parameterize what we're going to put in
so
in this case i like blue the guy really
likes blue so the parameter here is the
color equals blue that's nice um but
what if it doesn't work so uh obviously
it hasn't shown up there we go um
but like if it does error then it shows
the full stack trace
so you can understand what happened
uh let's have a go at executing one of
these so
uh
can someone shout out a color please
blue
again
sure i mean fine
so color equals blue
uh and a number please
42 the meaning of life of course
um so what this is doing is it's uh
taking the little bit of python everyone
here converting it into json because
that's how pigment works
uh and then it has gone off and ex
started process in the background uh
which is using papermill to execute oh
it happened so quickly um but actually
if i view the standard out
you can see that it has executed the
cells in order
uh it's converted it to a chipset
notebook
and here's our wonderful results with 42
points on it and it's blue
which is nice uh and within uh gets this
is what it looks like so
super super simple um to understand
what's going on here
uh this is some junk that jupiter text
puts at the top um but yeah you know
it's it's dead easy to understand what's
going to happen here um especially if
you're going to review this
um
yeah oh hang on yeah the schedule up so
this is uh schedule which is recently
added let's add a new schedule
so let's say i like what color
don't say
i think it already exists i'm going to
say light blue
um
okay so we select our uh notebook which
is the rainbow one
uh color equals
lights blue
let's generate pdf let's email it to me
and let's run it every minute because
i'm a mad lad
and then let's go
so we gotta wait until the turn of the
minute which uh knowing my luck is
probably 59 seconds time
but yeah essentially uh
it should uh start uh so it's going to
run at 31.
that's what we're going to hear
there it is it's running
and there it is
lovely so if i look at my inbox now i've
probably been spammed
um with with this pdf
which is probably underwhelming there
you go
lovely
so we can there's options to remove the
input code as well
but yeah essentially that is it that's
that's notebooker
um
yeah
so
let's go back to the presentation
that's not what i want
cool yeah um so yeah that's it uh have a
look at the github page for notebooker
um leave us a star
um come visit our booth to have a play
with a notebooker yourself
to see how easy it is
we man group also has a competition
which is ending at three o'clock today
to win a set of headphones i think
so yeah absolutely come come say hi um
are there any questions
thanks john
we've got plenty of time questions and
questions
not exactly the deepest question because
you go back one slide so i could take a
photo off
um yeah i also have a question thanks a
lot for the talk so
i think my main question is is that a
multi-tenant environment can multiple
users like restrict their permissions of
like who can see what for example like
some reports might be on the visible to
the users created them yeah great
question um so within
within man group we have some hedge
funds which are quite sensitive to
who can view what so there might be like
portfolio managers portfolio managers
who don't want other portfolio managers
to see what they're doing um so we
actually do have this use case um if you
use uh
basically if you put a reverse proxy on
top you can say for this specific url i
don't want people to view um this thing
so
if we go back to notebooker if it's
gonna work it's probably not gonna work
um yeah basically it's all namespaced by
the template name so if you put it in a
folder saying my private folder
you can say i don't want people to view
the results of this and i want never
want people to be able to execute it so
you can lock it down basically that way
with urls
but you don't have like any like
fine grained support
in the middle of itself so you need to
put it kind of like a crosstalk
yeah so you basically need to put a
wrapper on top um within no because
there's no fine grained permissions
structure um
yeah essentially
but we do have kind of a kind of a
nuclear approach where you can say no
one can access this instance we have
support for oidc um so you can basically
say no one should be able to access this
or the specific set of people should be
able to
thank you very much for the presentation
uh just one question uh regarding
keeping the history of the runs
would you be able to repeat an older run
as well
for example having date as a parameter
of the run so that you will be able to
run a sort of notebook for results of a
previous date something like that um so
the only
parameter so the only thing that would
you'd be able to rerun with is the
parameters themselves because you're
essentially executing from top to bottom
are you talking about the state of the
old notebook state i mean something
similar to what airflow offers you right
you've got a context state which is the
date of the data itself and that enables
you to go back in time and say okay for
whatever reason i have to repeat this
run for two days ago okay would that
enable you or you have to rely on
external sources
well yeah so i mean you'd be you need to
be able to reverse oh sorry um to revert
your data that you're operating on back
in time right so it depends on
what you're using um you need to kind of
use a temporal database of some sort um
you can
rerun it with the parameters that were
given two days ago that's that's fine um
but no there's no way to kind of uh
repeat history as it were
hey yeah this looks really cool i was
just wondering if i could use it for
julia notebooks as well as python
uh so only sports python at the moment
um
but i'm more than happy to give it a go
with julia yeah and that would be great
uh
it's over so obviously you know
contributions are welcome um but yeah
our focus is python because we only use
python internally um
yeah i'd love to explore that actually
that sounds pretty cool
hi uh thanks for the talk
um how do you handle virtual
environments or notebook kernels
uh yeah great question so
within your notebook templates
repository
you'll have a notebook requirements.txt
there
so essentially you add whatever you need
in this case so with the scheduler and
when you're executing it actually uses
the same virtual environment as the
notebook instance because it's all based
on python
so you would essentially need to
redeploy your instance if you wanted to
upgrade the version of whatever package
or you need to add a dependency
if you are running it externally however
um so say you've created a docker image
which has all the dependencies you need
um and it's just executing a notebook
and saving it to [ __ ] um then you can
kind of have that as a separate process
um but essentially yeah it's all using
the same virtual environment as is
so it's not possible at the moment to
have different environments for
each report
uh
no um basically because it yeah there
would be a lot of setup required to
actually get it up and running um or
you'd need to give it a separate docker
image or something like that
um so this is just kind of in in the
most simple case basically uh you
basically just have all of your
dependencies in one first length and
you're good to go
okay thanks
hi thanks for talk um
there was another question about
multi-tenant usage um so i see obviously
when people can execute um that that's
great you know there's no indication of
who executed
and could you talk a little bit more
about sharing in terms of i'm thinking
you know if i can use to use this in a
in a production environment um
i might want to for example have a
system user executing on a daily basis
as that might be my systemic batch run
on the day but what if i wanted users to
do kind of scenario testing during the
day how would i be able to differentiate
between the runs
yeah so um
that's
gonna you basically need to uh pick out
the username from oidc so if you've got
some authentication on top which
is kind of handled internally you need
to enrich the the metadata with what
you're doing so
in short no it doesn't exist just yet um
but that's that that's a really nice
idea i mean that that's it's an open
source project where we're trying to
build out requirements and things like
that
and feedback like that it's really
helpful um
so actually if you could raise uh an
issue on github then we'll look into
that because that i think would be
really nice
any other questions
hi there thanks for a great talk
so my question is really about your
vision but let me uh for this product of
our notebook
where it's going
and
like the things i see myself is there's
a framework called mercury for example
which is on demand execution of
notebooks like
having it a little bit like power bi
with parameters but you are replacing
that actually here sort of
and also like uh
like just like a data catalog a notebook
catalog or gallery right
where do you see this where it's where
is it going
uh yeah so i mean there's there's a
bunch of
ideas out there we're running a kind of
three or four person mini team within
man to build it out um so again new
feature requests so happily accepted um
in terms of where i'd like to see it
going is
if we could
improve the display of the reports and
kind of make it more into like uh you
know if you could have like probably
dash inside it as well that'd be really
nice it's kind of more dashboarding than
reporting um
if we could
uh turn it into some sort of thing where
like the the reports are basically a bit
more beautiful a bit more um useful for
the users to to share with
um
yeah i mean what would you like to see
out of it
is is yeah what i'm interested in yeah
first of all i would like to test it out
right to see where the weak points but
as people have like asked questions it's
probably there right around
authentication and stuff like that
yeah absolutely cool no um
that's you know that's an open space for
us and
yeah i'm super excited to
try and try and implement that
i'm a developer myself i love typing so
great let's thank john again
you